[拍手]
私は
14年前に日本に来ました
小学校が始まる前までの夏休みの間があ
箸の使い方を練習したり名前をカタカナで書く練習をしていました
初めて a
ガトー行く日がきて
そのクラスメイトの中に帰国しちゃう使った子がいました
その子は英語がとても超せて毎日一緒に楽しく英語でしゃべりながらどんな評価書が
必要なのか
フリートを読んで下さりん
いろいろ助けてくれました
その後は今でも仲良してい
その後も
給食をちゃんとができることも教えてくれました
昔から好き嫌いが激しくてい
アプないと肌着しか食べない時期もありました
私はよく給食を残す気があってー
ある日給食を残したままごちそうさまをしようとしたら
友達がまで残すの
横からをとってきて私がびっくりしてー
その日初めて給食を最後まで食べきりました
小学校はとても楽しくて
予定がきちんと決まっていてそれでも自由
どんな靴を着てもいいし遊ぶ時間はにあやります
小学校で学んだことはある
周りをサポートすること協調性の大切さです
中学校に上がったてきます
wiki がまったぺっ変わってしまいましたよ
自由がなくなった感じがしてい
学コン例えると学校が工場のような感じで生徒が製品になった感じがしました
補正や自己表現ができなくなった感じがしました
制限が増えること
みんなの雰囲気もバルクなりました
いじめも増えました
部活の強制されました
私は昔から絵を描くのがつき0
これお母さんのえるんですけど
言ったろ
美術部に入れば楽しいかなと思って
維持つべに指すればもうしました
はより始めて23回目が足りん
を得たりしてて
それで先生が訪ねてきました
ミレに書いてるの
聞かれて私はどうですよっ
ありました
そして先生があっ
ん
言えばって言ってその場でさ
私はとても落ち着きました
でもそれ以上に
むかついたんです
なんで私が
ただ楽しくお絵かきしたいだけなのにそんなこと言われなきゃいけないと思って
もうその引いたら
部活に行くのをやめました
中学生の時
私の
日本語がまだちょっとイマイチデー
会話とかできるしいいたいことも言える
a
家を読んでに入ったりも
できて感じもちょっと変えてたけど
やっぱ4年生の時生きたのでそれまでの感じとか
わからなくて後6年生の漢字もあるし中学校に上がるともっともっと難しい単語服役し
感じもふえっええ
どうしてもちょっと勉強に追いつけない状態でした
それで
近所の人々に
あえっとボランティアとして学校に来ていただいて別室で一緒に日本語の勉強しました
その方々のおかげで私の語学力がはるかに良くなりました
本当に感謝しています
3年生に上がる少し前
表紙に戻りなさい
とっ
先生に言われました
2年生の間に
いじめの問題があって
表紙に入れない状態でした
ずっとベーシックでリンクしていました
表示に戻り言われると
すごく心配ですか
また3年生で教室に戻ったらまた嫌な経験をしてしまうかな
すごく不安でした
学校でいじめの問題があると
また皆知ってると思うんですけど親が学校に呼ばれて先生と一緒に混乱をして今後どう
しますか
南
味を
話をします
day
私の親は
サイトも日本人ではないって日本語がちょっとわからないんですよね
だから
通訳者を学校に読んでー
それで混乱をします
しかし
通訳者はたいてい私が家族のしかし友人でさ
考えてみると
被害したか
ホンダに参加を指定
自分のいやだけ音何度も何を話してー
てその嫌な経験が
記憶に焼き付いてしまいます
とても問題があると思ってい
でも
やっぱり
いじめ対策もっと専門的な対策だ
必要だと思います
特に日本語のしゃべれない人たちのためのサポートがもっと必要だと思います
3練習になると
いきたい意向決める時があります
私真剣に考えてみて
何勉強したいかなぁ
考えてたら
給食
が思い浮かびました
私
日本人ではない家族の日本人ではない和食はに家で食べられないん
でも毎日おいしい給食が食べられる
見たことのないものを食べられる
でそれを私もいいで食べたいなぁと思って
どうしたら作れるようになるかな考えたら
よりだっ
先生に岐阜によーり学校ありますか
聞いたんですよ
先生があるよっ
入ってください
やさしいやっぱ思って
6位タイ
思って先生にそう伝えたら
先生に反対されました
みんなと同じように普通科に行きなさいと言われました
私がその学校に行きたいいうが無視された感じがし
とても悲しかったです
正直に言うと
私は学校は好きではありません
評価書の内容を安置するの依頼です
体験を通して学ぶのが付きです
料理学校に通えば
体験できる
ライフスキルを得られる実用できるものを得られるんですよね
だからそこに行きたいと思いました
皆さん
自分が興味のあること
いつでも何でも勉強してください
周りに合わせて普通に進まなくてもいい
海外に行くこともできます
留学もできます
一旦学校辞めて後でまた戻ることができます
制振静音ない通路があります
選択肢を本当に無限です
自分は自分だから
それを大事にしてほしいです
他人に自分の選択を負かすではいけません
なぜのが
他人に自分の選択を任せたら
あとでもし自分が失敗したときに
その人に
責任を押し付けることができるからです
自分の人生は
自分で選択してください
強いと思うし
不安だと思うけど
責任も増え c
でもそれよりも多くの自由を得られることができます
自分の決断や選択は
誰にも認められなってもいい
自分のが満足していればそれだけでいいのです
私が料理学校を卒業した後
今度は違うことを勉強してみたいと思う性心理学を勉強することにしました
実を言うと
大学は
1週間止めたかったです
でも
この4年間は自分のためになるだろうと思って
最後までやりました
こんなに早く
いやなのは初めてだったけど
自分を変えようと思って
この4年間をやりということにしました
大学で得たものは
時間の管理法
やらなきゃいけないことを先延ばしにして済み
ちゃんとやること
仕事に入線10位につける方法です
昔
私はすべてのものに対し0500でした
とても良くなりに考えたですね
自分に
完璧を求めちゃうから
途中で自分に満足しないと
その場で止めたりします
たし
気付いたんです
健康的な生活と
生産的な生活のバランスがたいしたという
大学に通った4年間
私は大きく成長したと思います
もし大学1年生の私にペットに出演できるかと聞かれたら
絶対鈍いと言ってました
大学に通っていた家ティ
大変で何度も止めたかったけど
不思議なことに卒業したあとまた戻りたくなりました
人間って不思議ですよね
皆さん
今何をやってい
自分を
自分自身誇りに思ってほしい
今まで達成したことに
ようです
達成したことに満足してください
みんな自分自身の道を歩んでここまで来るのに一生懸命取る起きてきました
その努力は認められるべきです
周りの人の意見を気にしないで自分を込めてください
最後に
皆さんにお伝えしたいことがあります
自分自身
正直でいれば
どんな状況でも
売れない自分が確立できる
ということです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]